[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio.
And I'm one of the engineers in
the Google Drive Developer
Relations Team.
Today I'm going to talk about
two of the Google products I
like most, Google Drive
and Apps Script.
If you don't know Apps Script,
Apps Script is basically
JavaScript on the cloud.
You can write your own
JavaScript code and have it
run on the Google Cloud and
access our services or third
party services.
It is basically JavaScript,
so you probably
know the syntax already.
It's not a new language
you have to learn.
What you might need to learn is
how to use the services we
have, and we have a service that
can be used to access and
manage your Google
Drive files.
And this is what I'm going
to talk about today.
I'm going to show you how to get
started with Apps Script
and how to use Apps Script to
create a file in Drive, share
it, check its properties,
and so on.
If you want to know more about
Apps Script, the good starting
point is our documentation,
which is at developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
And this is the page that
I have open right now.
So this is the main page for
the Google Apps Script
documentation.
It has get started guides.
It has tutorials.
It has all the news and updates
on the new features of
the product.
It has support channels.
And it has a complete
documentation set for all the
services and all the functions
you can use with Apps Script.
One of those is called DocsList
Service, and that's
the one we can use to access
Google Drive files.
If we check the documentation
for it, which I have it open
here, it exposes some basic
classes, including a main
service called DocsList, and
an object to represent the
file, a folder, or
a file type.
I'm going to show you
how to use them.
To write a script, your Google
Apps Script, you go to
script.google.com.
Let's do it.
I'm going to open a new tab,
go to script.google.com.
And what I see is this first
dialogue that asks me if I
want to create a new project.
I want to start with
a tutorial.
So if you're new, you might
want to start from there.
And if you want to create a new
script, you might want to
start with a blank project,
so an empty file.
Or there's some templates
we have for you
to get started faster.
And one of those is for Drive.
So I'm going to start
with this.
And this will make our life
much, much easier.
So I select Drive.
And I get a new script and this
web IDE, I'm going to
talk about it a bit more
in a few minutes.
And we have two functions
we can already use.
They're ready.
They do two things.
One of those lists files
in a folder.
And the other one moves
a file into a folder.
And obviously, we
can add our own.
I think the best way to get
started is to check one of
these functions first.
Let's check the first one called
List Files In Folder.
The Apps Script code
is JavaScript.
And it's very, very easy to
read, even if you don't know
Apps Script.
So basically, what we're doing
here in line 10 is that we are
asking the DocsList service to
get a folder by its name.
So if we want to use it in our
Drive account, we have to
replace the name Your
Folder with the name
of a folder we own.
So let me check what I have
in my Drive account.
I have it here.
I have some folders.
Let's say we're going to use
TestFolder, which is here,
which contains two super
important files.
So, let's go back to Apps Script
and replace Your Folder
with TestFolder, which is
the name of my folder.
With this line, we get a
handle to the folder.
And then the next line, line 11,
we get a list of all the
files in that folder.
What the rest of the function
does is iterating through all
the documents in this folder.
And for each of them, log--
which is done on line 18--
log the name of the file.
Let's try to run it.
So first, I'm going to save it
because I changed something.
So, Save button.
This is easy.
This is the first time I saved
this project, so I have to
give it a name.
Default name is Untitled
Project.
We can do better than that.
Let's say Drive AppsScript.
Very original.
And this is now saved.
And it is going to be available
in my Drive account.
So any time, I can go back to
it, open it, edit, use it
again, and so on.
If I want to run it, I have to
select the function that I
want to start with.
So I have two.
And we decided we're going to
use List Files In Folder.
So I select this.
And now I have these two new
buttons that I can use.
One is to run the code.
And the other one is
to debug the code.
Because this web IDE also allows
you to run code in
debugging mode, which means you
can put [INAUDIBLE], you
can inspect the values of the
variables, and so on.
I'm not going I show you that.
But that is covered very, very
well in the documentation.
And we also have some other
videos showing how to use the
degugger for Apps Script.
So let's say we run it.
This is the first time
we run this code.
So Apps Script realizes that
we never authorized this
script to have access
to my documents.
So it automatically checks the
code that I'm running and
identifies all the requirements
I have.
And the only requirement I have
to run this script is to
give access to my docs
in a read/write mode.
It asks for read/write mode.
In this script, in this
function, we're only reading.
But the other function
is also writing.
And since one function can call
another, the whole script
has to be authorized for both
reading and writing.
So I authorize the script.
This is only required the first
time you run the app or
anytime you change something in
the code that requires new
authorization.
So I'm going to authorize.
That's it.
I didn't write any authorization
code.
This makes Apps Script very,
very easy to get started with
and to write scripts.
So this is now authorized.
I can close this window, go back
to the IDE, and run it.
As I said, this function will
list all files in a folder and
log their names.
So I run it.
I won't see anything unless
I check the log.
The log is available anytime.
It's very, very convenient for
debugging when you want to run
something and log in
what's going on.
And it's available in the
View menu and the logs.
So what I'm expecting to see
here is two lines with the
names of my files, Really
New and Untitled.
Fancy names.
And if we go back to my
TestFolder, these are exactly
the files I have.
So this has worked.
Very, very easy.
We did that in less than
10 lines of code.
This is great.
But we can also do a much,
much more with
Apps Script and Drive.
All of the methods are
documented in the
documentation page that
I showed you before.
But the IDE also gives you
autocompletion, syntax aligning.
So it's very easy to
write new code.
Let's try to write
a new function.
Let's say I want to create a
file on Drive and share it
with someone.
So let's say the function--
I'm going to define
a function.
This is JavaScript syntax,
createFile.
And now you should pass
parameters to the functions,
good programming.
But this time we're going
to hard code something.
Then, obviously, you
can make it better.
With createFile, the first
thing we want to do is
creating a file.
So let's say var file equals
DocsList dot--
as soon as I type the dot,
I get autocompletion.
And I get suggestions on all
the methods that I can use.
So there are three overloads
for createFile.
Let's say I choose this one
that takes the name of the
file and the string
for the content.
There are two more.
You can get all the details
from the documentation.
So this autocompletion puts the
method signature there.
I just have to replace
the place holder.
So one of those is name.
Let's say my new drive file.
And the other one is contents,
which is another string which
is going to be the text
content for the file.
So this is a new Drive
file that I
created with Apps Script.
And that's it.
If we run this, this
will create a file.
But we want to do more.
I said we want to share it.
So we can do more things
in a function.
Obviously, you should separate
functionalities in multiple
functions, abstract each one
from the other, you know that.
But still, this is an example.
So let's do more in
the same function.
The first thing I want to do is
to get the file ID from the
file I just created, because
the file ID is the unique
identifier that allows me to do
more things with this file.
So I'm going to sort
it in a variable.
Var fileID equals file.
As you're going to see, I type
dot, and I get autocompletion
for file, which is a
generic variable.
But Apps Script realizes that
as that is the output of the
createFile method, this is going
to be a file object.
So this is very smart
autocompletion.
I'm going to get multiple
various methods I can use.
And the one I want
is called getID.
So I have a file ID
in the variable.
And if we want to prove
it, we can log it.
Logger.log, and I
can log file ID.
This code will create a file,
get the file ID of the file we
just created, and log it.
But I said we also
want to share it.
So let's add an extra step.
Sharing a file with Apps Script
is very, very easy.
All you have to do is to call
the add viewers or add editors
methods of the file itself.
So I can do file.addViewer.
And I can use an email
address or a user.
Or I can add multiple email
addresses at the same time.
So let's say I'm going to
use an email address.
And let's put another
test account I
have on the same domain.
If we want to check if that
works, well, we can obviously
go back to the UI and see who
the file is shared to.
But we can also do that
programmatically.
So let's extend this code to get
all the viewers for that
file and log them.
So we can say var viewers equals
file.getViewers, which
will give us an array
of users.
Viewers is going to be
an array of users.
We can use a follow up to print
information for each one.
So we can do for var I equals 0,
I less than viewers.length,
I plus plus.
We can do a Logger.log, viewers
i dot getEmail.
And we get the email address
with that user.
Let's close parentheses,
semicolon, Save,
and we can run this.
So, before we do it, let's see
what is going to happen now.
I'm going to create a new file
called My New Drive File with
some text content.
I'm going to log the file ID.
I'm going to add another
user as Viewer.
And I'm going to log the email
addresses of all the viewers
for his file.
So I go back to the drop down
menu here and select my new
method, which I call createFile,
and run it.
I didn't need to give more
permissions to the document,
to the app, because I've already
given read and write
access to the script
to my Docs account.
So even though I added the new
function, the same set of
permissions I had before is
enough to run the new code.
It's done.
We can check the log.
Let's check logs
from View Logs.
Well, first line is the ID,
is this Unix string.
This is the unique ID for
the file I just created.
And these two are the email
addresses of the users who
have read access to the file.
One of those, the first
one, is my account.
I'm the owner, so I
can read the file.
And the second one is the
one that I just added.
Let's see how this gets
reflected in the Drive UI.
I go back to Drive.
I created a file in the root.
So I actually see two things.
Drive Apps Script, you can
notice the icon is the Apps
Script project that I created.
So this is the project
that contains the
code that I just ran.
And my new drive file is the
text file we just created with
the Apps Script code.
So if I open it, it's going
to be a text file.
So this is the viewer.
This is exactly the content
I put in it.
And if I go to the Share
dialogue, I can see that this
file is only available to me--
and I'm the owner--
and to this other user,
who is a viewer, so
only has read access.
Great.
I think you all realize how easy
it is to use Apps Script
to manage your Drive files.
There is a lot more we
can do with that.
And before I wrap up, I just
want to go back to the Docs
for a second and show you
that there's so many
methods you can use.
Let me mention some of those.
You might be interested in
knowing what you can do with
Apps Script and Drive.
So with DocsList, which is
our main service, you
can create a file.
You can look for files
using a query string.
So let's say you know the name
but you don't know the ID.
You can get all the files
that match that name.
You can get files, give an ID.
Obviously that would mean
you know how to get
that specific file.
You can get folders.
And you have some convenient
methods to get a specific
folder, including the
root folder, which
might be very useful.
Then you have a file type
enum, which is used to
categorize each file you have
on Google Drive, and then a
class file, which is
what we just used.
And that class has methods to
add editors, to add viewers,
as we said, as we used, to get
all the properties, all the
metadata, from that file,
including the date when it was
created, the ID, when it was
last updated, what's the name
of the file, who's the owner,
if it has any parents, which
means folders it is
in, size, URL.
And obviously, as you can add
editors and viewers, you can
obviously remove them.
Some of the methods.
You can rename a file.
You can start a file.
You can move a file to
trash, and so on.
There's a lot more there.
I'm not going to
list them all.
But I strongly advise you to go
to this page and check what
you can do with Apps Script.
OK.
Remember, if you want to start
playing with it, just go to
script.google.com.
You can start with a blank
project, but if you start with
a dry project, it will be much,
much easier for you to
learn about it.
Thank you very much.
If you have any questions,
please reach out to us on
Google+ and Stack Overflow.
If not, well, let's see
you next time on
Google Developers Live.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]